NO MATTER WHO BECOMES INDIA'S
NEXT PRIME MINISTER, THEIR
ELECTION WILL HAVE GLOBAL
CONSEQUENCES.
OUR OWN JASON JONES HAS MORE.
>> Jason: INDIA IS HAVING AN
ELECTION. AND I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
TOLD IT'S AN INCREDIBLE PLACE TO
VISIT. BUT I'D RATHER AVOID
DYSENTERY IN 120 DEGREE
WEATHER. SO INSTEAD I WENT
TO THE INDIA CONSULATE IN NEW
YORK AND MET WITH AMBASSADOR --
(MISPRONOUNCING NAME) -- I MET
WITH THE AMBASSADOR.
MR. AMBASSADOR, I AM NOT AT ALL
EMBARASSED TO ADMIT THAT I KNOW
NOTHING ABOUT INDIA.
>> YEAH, WELL IT'S ALWAYS GOOD
TO START.
>> I HEAR YOU GUYS
ARE HAVING A LITTLE ELECTION.
>> YES. INDIA IS ACTUALLY THE
GREATEST DEMOCRACY IN THE
WORLD.
>> NO, THAT'S THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
THAT IS THE GREATEST
DEMOCRACY IN THE WORLD.
>> NO, HOW DO YOU DEFINE IT?
>> Jason: OH, I DON'T KNOW, 121
MILLION PEOPLE VOTING IN OUR
LAST ELECTION.
>> AND WE HAVE 814 MILLION
REGISTERED VOTERS.
>> Jason: OK, BUT THAT'S,
THAT'S, THAT'S IN RUPEES.
HOW MANY IN AMERICAN?
>> I THINK WE DON'T CONVERT
PEOPLE INTO RUPEES AND DOLLARS.
>> I KNOW WHY YOU KNOW SO MUCH
ABOUT US BECAUSE WE'RE THE BEST.
BUT, WHY DON'T WE KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT YOU?
>> YOU KNOW, YOU CAN'T
UNDERSTAND INDIA IN ONE LIFE.
A PERSON SAY FROM TAMIL
NADU IN THE SOUTH WOULD NOT
UNDERSTAND THE LANGUAGE OF
SOMEBODY IN THE NORTHEAST.
MY WIFE OFTEN THINKS WHEN I SAY
NO, SHE THINK IT'S YES.
>> Jason: HOW DO YOU SAY NO?
>> I SAY IT LIKE THIS.
>> Jason: WHAT, YOU SAY NO LIKE
THIS?
>> SO, NOW ACTUALLY YOU'RE
CONFUSING ME.
I REALLY DON'T KNOW.
>> Jason: YOU DON'T REMEMBER
HOW YOU SAY NO?
>> AT ONE LEVEL INDIA IS
VERY CONFUSING, AT
ANOTHER LEVEL IT'S
VERY, VERY FASCINATING.
>> Jason: WELL, AMBASSADOR, IF
YOUR ELECTIONS ARE SO
FASCINATING THEN
WHY IS THIS ALL I CAN FIND ABOUT
INDIA ON AMERICAN TELEVISION?
>> GOOD RICE, GOOD CURRY, GOOD
GANDHI, LET'S HURRY.
>> THE COVERAGE HERE IS,
I WOULD SAY, LOPSIDED.
IT DOESN'T CAPTURE THE
COMPLEXITY, IT DOESN'T CAPTURE
THE ENTHUSIASM OF INDIAN PEOPLE.
IT'S, IT'S, IT'S SOMETHING THAT
YOU MUST SEE TO BELIEVE.
>> Jason: PLEASE DO NOT DARE
ME TO GO TO INDIA.
>> THIS IS REALLY A FASCINATING
ELECTION.
>> Jason: DON'T MAKE ME GO TO
INDIA.
>> NO, YOU MUST GO.
>> Jason: BUT, I DON'T WANT TO
GO.
>> SITTING BEHIND A DESK IN THE
U.S., AND
APPRECIATING OR UNDERSTANDING
INDIAN ELECTIONS IS ALMOST NEXT
TO IMPOSSIBLE.
>> Jason: OK, YOU KNOW WHAT,
PAL?
I AM GOING TO GO FIND SOMEONE
WHO IS WILLING TO TRAVEL TO
INDIA.
>> YOU BETTER GO. YOU BETTER GO.
>> Jason: I'M NOT GOING.
>> YOU BETTER GO.
>> Jason: LUCKILY, I KNEW
SOMEONE WHO LOVED INDIA.
(KNOCKING)
GUESS WHAT? WHO THE (bleep) ARE
YOU?
>> HI, I'M JORDAN.
>> YEAH, I DON'T CARE. WHERE'S
MANDVI?
>> HE'S HAS AN HBO SHOW.
>> Jason: WELL, GOOD NEWS. YOU
ARE GOING TO INDIA.
>> OH, I CAN'T. I'M A RACIST.
>> Jason: JESSICA.
>> I CAN'T. I'M RACIST, TOO.
>> LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE GOING TO
INDIA, HAVE A NICE TRIP.
>> I REALLY DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE
TO COME TO INDIA. YOU KNOW,
I'M PRETTY HUNGRY. LET'S GO GRAB
SOME CHILLED MONKEY BRAINS.
IS THAT RACIST, BY THE WAY?
(MUSIC)
>> OKAY, LET'S AVOID THAT CIVIL
WAR.
NO, NO, CAN'T FLY IN THEIR
AIRSPACE.
WHOA, TOO MANY DRONES THERE.
THERE WE GO. DELHI.
JUST ONE LOOK AT THE CHAOS OF
INDIA'S CAPITAL CITY AND IT
WAS CLEAR THERE WAS NO WAY THIS
DEMOCRACY COULD EQUAL
OURS. FOR EXAMPLE,
IN THE U.S. YOU ARE FREE TO
CHOOSE ONE OF TWO PARTIES AND IN
INDIA YOU HOLY (bleep) THERE'S A
LOT OF CHOICES.
OK, BUT IN AMERICA, A STAGGERING
23% OF OUR YOUTH PLAN ON VOTING
IN OUR NEXT ELECTIONS.
MATCH THAT, INDIA.
>> AS YOU KNOW 60 YEARS WE HAVE
BEEN WITH THE CONGRESS PARTY,
WE'RE TRYING SOMETHING
NEW THIS TIME.
>> SO, YOU'RE 15 YEARS OLD AND
YOU ACTUALLY CARE ABOUT
POLITICS.
>> YES, WE DO BECAUSE IT IS OUR
FUTURE.
>> REALLY? YOU GUYS ALL CARE
ABOUT POLITICS?
>> YES.
>> YES, OF COURSE I CARE
ABOUT POLITICS BECAUSE OUR
FUTURE DEPENDS ON US SO WE
CARE A LOT ABOUT POLITICS.
>> YOU CARE THAT MUCH YOU
DIDN'T EVEN NOTICE THAT
MOTORCYCLE.
>> YEAH.
>> WOW. AND WITH 150 MILLION
FIRST-TIME VOTERS, MAYBE INDIA'S
YOUTH IS A LITTLE MORE
ENGAGED THAN OURS.
BUT IN AMERICA, OUR POLITICIANS
KNOW HOW TO SPEAK TO EACH
COLOR-CODED GROUP.
>> I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
DADDY YANKEE.
>> WHO LET THE DOGS OUT?
WHO?
>> SO, INDIA, DOES YOUR
DEMOCRACY PANDER TO ITS
MINORITIES?
I'M LOOKING FOR MINORITIES --
PEOPLE WHO LOOK -- MINORITIES --
I DON'T KNOW, WHAT IS YOUR
MINORITY HERE?
HEY PAL, YOU SPEAK ENGLISH?
>> YES.
>> Jason: YOU DO. OKAY. WHAT'S
UH,
WHAT DO MINORITIES LOOK LIKE
HERE?
>> YOU.
>> Jason: LIKE ME?
>> YES.
>> Jason: OH YES. WHY AM I
ASKING THE QUESTIONS THEN?
HERE, YOU TAKE IT. I'LL TAKE
THAT.
HERE, LET'S, LET'S SWAP THEM.
JUST READ THEM.
>> WHY ARE WHITE PEOPLE SO FAT?
>> Jason: WHAT?
>> WHY ARE, WHY ARE WHITE PEOPLE
SO FAT?
>> Jason: NO, I HEARD YOU. IT'S
JUST VERY OFFENSIVE.
>> WHY ARE WHITE PEOPLE SO LAZY?
>> Jason: YOU CAN'T SAY THAT!
>> I HAVE 30 OTHERS, DO YOU WANT
ME TO KEEP GOING?
>> Jason: NO. I DON'T WANT YOU
TO KEEP GOING.
IS THAT WHAT THIS INTERVIEW IS
ALL ABOUT? TO MAKE ME LOOK
FOOLISH AS A MINORITY?
THE INTERVIEW IS OVER.
BUT, THE REAL WORK IS BEGINNING.
BECAUSE EVERYWHERE I WENT IN
INDIA, EVERYONE HAD AN OPINION
ON POLITICS.
>> EVERY PERSON'S
ASPIRATION, EVERY SINGLE VOTE.
>> Jason: YOU KNOW, I APPRECIATE
ALL THAT BUT I'VE GOT A LONG,
LONG LINE OF GUYS I'VE GOT TO
GET TO.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO TALK ABOUT
POLITICS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> Jason: OF COURSE, YOU ALSO
WANT TO TALK ABOUT POLITICS.
>> -- LEADERSHIP AND MANAGEMENT.
AND IN A COUNTRY WITH
1.2 BILLION PEOPLE, 780 OFFICIAL
LANGUAGES AND 330 MILLION HINDU
GODS, CUTTING THROUGH THE NOISE
WAS GOING TO TAKE A WHILE.
>> Jon: JASON JONES, WE'LL BE
RIGHT BACK!